e aí galera que assistir meu canal do
boi com vocês eu estou muito feliz estou
muito bem e eu acabei de chegar aqui ele
é o hoje sexta feira dia 2 de outubro se
você estiver assistindo hoje no dia 2 de
outubro de milão mandou avisar que o
show que beyoncé hoje no auditório do
centro de convenções de ilhéus nove
horas da noite com ela adora curtir uma
família podia porque o show é muito bom
eu indico e amanhã sábado dia 3 de
outubro em feira de santana depois da
manhã em serrinha
tudo aqui na bahia você compra um
ingresso é só entrar no site
www.ingresso.com.br já tem ingresso para
todas as idades e mais as outras têm
salvador tem são caetano são paulo por
ficar com isso aqui pra falar porque o
homem é um bicho difícil lidar com
certeza é mais a mulher e várias coisas
que eu acho engraçadas embaixo um pouco
estranho por exemplo que a mulher que as
10 ruins linda maravilhosa aí vai fazer
alguma coisa que é bom em época dessa
união que ela quebrou ela corta todas as
unhas da mão é de puxar mas não é tão
bonito que foi o seu contrato não é
porque basa que aí ficou diz completando
o time que conta toda amazônia não
entendo por que o homem ele só deixa o
prefeito uma unha que é passar a cabeça
na cartola só em 2010 1 e quebrou um é
arrancar 9 também busco tantas um é um
disco tão pouco é cartão 10 1 e na tira
uma foto com 15 o da gobatti engraçado e
mulher é o sutiã que a mulher não sei se
a perceber mais correcta curso tinha
mais casa amarrada
agora quando tirou o sutiã da arena
porque mulher sempre chamava a amiga
para poder morrer nunca vai sozinha
sempre tem que ir com os amigos parece
que um mesmo comprimido da outra vez eu
fiquei num com o primeiro toque e um
homem diz quando o outro chama com o pai
no banheiro e agora nem aonde no
banheiro e fazer o quê e japão já ali
ainda chocou button outra coxa muito
engraçado mulher que é que a gente chama
tirar foto num primeiro momento ela
sempre neca tirar fotos só que ela nega
já iria tirar foto e e joaquim vieira
foto foto não me tira foto não eu não o
menino beijo negócio de voto não tirar
foto não vai precisar daqui até mais
bonito ainda a frança vai o chico da
mulher tira foto acho interessante o
seguinte às vezes a em casa aí amiga vai
mandar foto você não é exata ela manda
quatro fora e qual que eu gosto local e
as quatro pontes não gostei muita
primeira assim a a segunda ea terceira
neta agora a quarta pra mim tá muito
feio pode ter pelo amor de deus 30
segundos depois estava estável agora foi
que ela postou a quarta e mulheres pra
ver as fotos do seu lado não deixa não
saber porque para tirar uma foto para
prestar ela tinha 100 só que as fotos
são tudo igual só muda a posição da mão
que ela bota assinalável é tudo assim ó
e qual foi a junta tirando foto me pode
ter na sua cabeça a certeza que esta
foto vai demorar que só uma desgraça
porque sei que preciso achar bonita uma
vai ser achar pena podem tirar de novo
mas assim ou assim assim ou assim assim
a outra sai assim e quando ele sai assim
a outra filha e assim sucessivamente a
amiga saiu uma foto que as 4h bonita
amigas já mudou o presidente o brasil
ganhou a copa só lhe perguntou o que me
chama muita atenção é quando mulher bola
a maquiagem não sei se você quer homem
saiba existe negócio chamado rímel e
necessita de uma precisão cirúrgica para
não borrar só que o homem nem nota essas
coisas que não têm essas coisas é quem
assina e michael não vai ficar bonita
pra você vai ficar bonita faz outra
mulher e apela para fincar
a água é bonita também porque qualquer
detalhe com a mulher de max bela boa
maquiagem pra gente que é homem é mais
ou menos assim que passar o nininho o
meu deus droga morrer tudo meta vou ter
que fazer tudo de novo para elas é mais
ou menos assim que passar o rio o meu
droga ainda maquiagem do tinha medo de
fazer tudo de novo mesmo após a chegada
tardia é por isso que tinha uma mulher
que vocês são assim são diferenças são
hoje um concelho como um choro a mulher
cmm ainda se frase que tem que ter
trabalho disse pra gente mesmo se você
gostou de serviço e deixam gostei aqui
no youtube que me ajuda demais voltar lá
no facebook eu postei de novo ao papá
última postagem do vídeo novo no
facebook não esquece marcar um amigo o
amigo nos comentários que só ajuda a
trazer gente nova no canal ajuda o canal
crescer se inscreve no carnaval nunca
perder nenhum vídeo que me acompanha nas
redes sociais esse aqui é menos 97 esse
é o meu instagram e esse é o meu twitter
se você diria é o bahia hoje sexta feira
dia 2 tem show aqui em no auditório do
centro de convenções
amanhã sábado dia 31 em feira de santana
g4 em serrinha de 9 10 e 11 em salvador
bahia valeu é nóis falou um beijão
galera valeu